Kobe Bryant's public memorial is set to
happen later this month a source tells
ET the ceremony will be held on Monday
February 24th at the Staples Center in
downtown Los Angeles the source adds
there were conversations about possibly
having the ceremony at the LA Coliseum
to fit more people but ultimately the
Staples Center made the most sense as it
was such a big part of Kobe's life my
mentality is it's a way of life
of course the 24th is a significant date
picked to coincide with Kobe's jersey
number what the day will be a way for LA
to celebrate a man that meant so much to
the city grieving fans have flocked to
the Staples Center since Kobe his
daughter Gianna and seven others
tragically lost their lives on January
26 Kobe's wife Vanessa Bryant has
personally requested to keep items left
behind at the makeshift memorial
including shirts hats paintings and
basketballs nearly 1,400 basketballs
have been collected and flowers left at
the memorial will be composted and
spread outside the arena on Wednesday
night vanessa attended a tribute to her
late 13 year old daughter Gianna sharing
pics and videos of Gigi's Jersey
retirement ceremony at Harbor Day School
in Corona del Mar California heartfelt
speeches were given by Gianna's
classmates teachers and her basketball
coach
competitors that I've ever seen